the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so if you remember last time we looked
at parametric equations
as a way of describing the motion of a
point that moves in the plane or in
space as a function of time or your
favorite parameter that will tell you
how far the motion has progressed and I
think we did in detail the example of
the cycloid which is the curve traced by
a point on wheel that's rolling on a
flat surface so we have this example
where we have this wheel that's rolling
on the x axis and we have this point on
the wheel and as it moves around it
faces a trajectory that looked
Mijares like this okay so in trying a
new color is this visible from the back
so no more blue
okay
so remember in general we are trying to
find the position so X of T y of T may
be Z of T flow in space of a moving
point along a trajectory and one way to
think about this is in terms of the
position vector so the position vector
is just the vector whose components are
the coordinates of the point okay so if
you prefer that's the same thing as the
vector from the origin to the moving
point so maybe our point is here P so
this vector here this vector here is
vector o P and that's also the position
vector R of T
so just to give you again that example
if I take the cycloid for a wheel of
wages one and let's say that we are
going at unit speed so that the angle
that we used as a parameter less time is
the same thing as time when the position
vector in this case we found to be just
to make sure that I have it right t
minus sine T and cosine T no one minus
cosine T okay same that's that formula
that you should have in your notes from
last time except we had theta instead of
T because we were using the angle but
now I'm saying we're moving at unit
speed so time and angle are the same
thing so okay so now what's interesting
about this is we can analyze the motion
in no detail okay so now that we know
the position of a point as a function of
time we can try to study how it varies
and about fueler things like the speed
and the acceleration okay so let's start
with speed well so in fact we can do
better than speed let's not start with
speed so speed is a number it tells you
how fast you're going you know along the
trajectory I mean if you're driving in a
car
then you know it tells you how fast
you're going but unless you have one of
these fancy cars with a GPS it doesn't
tell you in which direction you're going
and that's useful information too if
you're trying to figure out what your
trajectory is so in fact there's two
aspects to it one is how fast you're
going and theorize in what direction
you're going that means actually we
should use a vector maybe to think about
this and so that's called the velocity
vector
and the way we can get it so it's called
usually V so V here stands for velocity
moment for vector and you just get it by
taking the derivative of the position
vector with respect to time okay now
it's our first time writing this kind of
thing with a vector so the basic hole is
you can take the derivative of a vector
quantity just by taking the derivatives
of each component okay so that's just DX
DT dy DT and if you have a Z component
this is it so let me
okay so
okay so let's see what it is for the for
the cycloid so in the example of a
cycloid well so what do we get when we
take the derivative of this formula up
there well so T the derivative of T is 1
minus cosine T the derivative of 1 is 0
the derivative of minus cosine T is sine
T very good that's at least one thing
you should remember from single variable
calculus hopefully you remember even
more than that ok so that's the velocity
vector it tells us at any time how fast
we are going in inward direction so for
example observe remember last time at
the end of class we were trying to
figure out what exactly happens near the
bottom point you know when we have this
motion that seems to stop and go
backwards and we answered that one way
but let's try to understand it in terms
of velocity what if I plug T equals zero
in here
then 1 minus cosine T is 0 sine T is 0
the velocity is 0 so at that time at
that particular time our point is
actually not moving of course it's been
moving just before and it starts moving
just afterwards it's just you know the
instant advantage or instant the speed
is zero so that's a slightly
maybe counterintuitive thing that
something is moving at at that time it's
actually stopped now let's see so that's
a vector and it's useful but if you want
just the usual speed as a number then
what will you do well you will just take
exactly the magnitude of this vector so
speed which is the scalar quantity is
going to be just the magnitude of the
vector V okay so in this case well it
would be square root of one minus cosine
T squared plus sine squared T and if you
expand that well so you will get taking
it more space that's going to be square
root of one minus two cosine T plus
cosine squared T plus sine squared T
seems to simplify a little bit because
we have cosine squared plus sine square
that's one okay so it's going to be
square root of two minus two cosine T so
at this point if I was going to ask you
when is the speed the smallest of the
largest you could answer based on that C
at T equals zero well that turns out to
be zero the point is not moving at T
equals pi that ends up being square root
of two plus two which is four so that's
two and that's when you actually at the
top of the arch and that's one of the
point is moving the fastest in fact
where it's moving twice as fast as the
wheel because the wheel is moving to the
right at unit speed and the point is
also rotating so it's moving to the
right at unit speed relative to the
center so that the two effects add up
and give you a speed of two anyway
that's a formula we can get
okay now what about acceleration so here
I put one you've adverse serious
discrepancy between the usual will be
intuitive notion of acceleration the one
that you are aware of when you drive a
car and the one that we'll be using so
you might think acceleration is just the
derivative of speed you know if my car
goes 50 mile 55 miles an hour on the
highway then it's going at constant
speed it's not accelerating but let's
say that I'm taking a really tight turn
then I'm going to feel something you
know there's some force being exerted
and in fact there is a sideways
acceleration at that point even for the
speed is not changing so the definition
will take of acceleration is as a vector
and the acceleration vector is just the
derivative of a velocity vector
so even if speed is constant that means
even if a length of the velocity vector
stays the same the vector velocity
vector can still rotate and as it
rotates that produces acceleration okay
and so this is the notion of
acceleration that's relevant in physics
for that when you write F equals MA
that's really what a you know that's the
a that you have in mind here it's a
vector of course if you're moving in a
straight line then the two notions are
the same acceleration is also going to
be along the line and it's going to have
to do with the derivative of speed but
in general that's not quite the same so
for example let's look at the cycloid if
we take the example of a cycloid well
what's the derivative of 1 minus cosine
T it's sine T and what's the derivative
of sine T cosine T ok so the
acceleration vector is sine T cosine T
so in particular let's look at what
happens at time T equals zero when the
point is not moving well the
acceleration vector there will be zero
comma one so what that means is that if
I look at my trajectory at this point
well then the acceleration vector is
pointing in that direction
it's the unit vector in the vertical
direction so my point is not moving at
that particular time but it's
accelerating up so that means actually
that as it comes down first its slowing
down when it stops here and then it
reverses going back up okay so that's
another way to understand what we were
saying
time that the trajectory at that point
has a vertical tangency because that's
the direction in which the motion is
going to occur just before and just
after time zero okay any questions about
that
okay so I should insist maybe on one
thing which is that so we can
differentiate vectors just component by
component okay and we can differentiate
vector expressions according to certain
rules that we'll see in a moment one
thing that we cannot do it's not true
that the length of dr/dt so which is the
speed is equal to the length R DT this
is completely false and they are really
not the same okay so if you have to
differentiate the length of a vector
then basically you're in trouble if you
really really want to do it well the
length of a vector is the square root of
the sums of the squares of the
components and from that you can use
formula for the derivative of the square
root and the chain rule and various
other things and you can get there but
it will not be a very nice expression
there is no simple formula for this kind
of thing
fortunately we almost never have to
compute this kind of thing because after
all it's not very relevant quantity
what's more relevant might be this one
this is actually the speed this one I
don't know what it means you know okay
so let's continue our exploration so the
next concept that I want to define
instead of arc length so arc length is
just the distance that you have traveled
along the curves okay so if you're in a
cow you know it has this mileage counter
that tells you how far you've gone how
much fuel you've used if it's a fancy
car and what it does is it actually it
integrates the speed over time to give
you the arc length along the trajectory
of a cow so the usual notation that
we'll have is s for arc length I am not
quite sure how you get an S out of this
but it's the usual notation okay so s is
the distance traveled along the
trajectory
and for that to make sense of course we
need to fix a reference point maybe on
the cycloid we'd say it's a distance
starting from the origin in general
maybe you will say you start at time
equals no T equals zero but it's a
convention you could decide you know if
you knew in advance you could have
actually your gas mileage counter to
count backwards you know from the point
where the guy will die and stop working
I mean that would be sneaky freaky but
you know you could have certainly a
negative arc length that gets closer and
closer to 0 1 gets to 0 at the end of
the trajectory or anything you want
I mean arc length could be positive or
negative typically it's negative when
you're before the reference point and
positive afterwards so now how does it
relate to the things we've seen where
well so in particular you know how do
you relate arc length and time well so
there's a simple relation which is that
the rate of change of arc length versus
time whether that's going to be the
speed at which are moving because the
speed as a scalar quantity tells you how
much distance you're covering a unit
time
okay and in fact to be completely honest
I should put an absolute video here
because there's examples of curves maybe
where your motion is going back and
forth along the same curve and then you
know you don't want to keep counting out
lengths all the time actually maybe you
want to say that the arc length
increases then decreases along the curve
I mean you get to choose how you count
it but in this case you know if you are
moving back and forth it would make more
sense to have the up line first increase
then decrease increase again and so on
so
so if you want to know really what the
arc length is then basically the only
way to do it is to integrate speed
that's this time so if you wanted to
know how long an arch of cyclo it is you
know you have this nice looking curve
how long is it well you'd have to
basically integrate this quantity from T
equals zero to 2pi and save a trough I
don't really know how to integrate that
so we don't actually have a formula for
the length at this point however we'll
see one later using a cool trick and
multivariable calculus so
for now we'll just leave a formula like
that and we don't know how long it is
well you know you can put that into your
calculator and get a numerical value but
that's the best I can offer now another
useful notion is the unit tangent vector
to the trajectory so the usual notation
is t hat it has a hat because it's a
unit vector and T because it's tangent
now how do we get this unit tangent
vector so maybe I should have pointed
out before that you know if you're
moving along some trajectory so you're
going in bad direction then when you're
at this point the velocity vector is
going to be tangent to the trajectory it
tells you the direction of motion in
particular so if you want a unit vector
that goes in the same direction all you
have to do is just rescale it so that
its length becomes 1 so it's V divided
by magnitude of V
okay
so it seems like now we have a lot of
different things that should be related
in some way so let's let's see what we
can say well we can say that D R by DT
so that's the velocity vector that's the
same thing as if I use the chain rule
DRDs times D s DT okay so let's think
about these things so this guy here
we've just seen that's the same as the
speed so this one here should be V
divided by its length so that means this
actually should be the unit tangent
vector so let me rewrite that it's T DS
DT so maybe if I actually stated
directly that way see I'm just saying
the velocity vector has a length and the
direction the length is the speed the
direction is tangent to the trajectory
so the speed is dsdt
and the tangent vector is t hat and
that's how we get this so let's try it
just to see why
DRDs should be t well let's think of
drds DRDs means you know position vector
r means you have the origin which is
somewhere out there and the vector R is
here so DRDs means we move by a small
amount Delta s along the trajectory by a
certain distance Delta s and we look at
how the position vector changes well
we'll have a small change let me call
that vector Delta R corresponding to the
size it was meant to the length Delta s
and now Delta R should be essentially
roughly equal to well its direction will
be tangent to the trajectory if I take a
small enough interval then the motion
will be almost tangent to the trajectory
times the length of it will be Delta s
the distance that I have traveled maybe
I should sorry maybe I should we explain
that on a separate board
okay
so let's say that we have an amount of
time delta T so let's zoom in to that
curve okay so we have R at time T we
have R at time T plus delta T this
vector here I will call Delta R the
length of this vector is Delta s and the
direction is essentially that of a
tangent vector so Delta s over delta T
that we amount that the distance
traveled divided by the time that's
going to be close to the speed and Delta
R is approximately T times Delta s so
now if I divide both sides by delta T I
get this and if I take the limit as
delta T tends to 0 then I get the same
formula with derivatives and with an
equality into the pen approximation the
approximation becomes better and better
if I go to smaller intervals
okay are there any questions about this
yes
yes that's quite so okay so let's be
more careful actually so you're asking
about whether of a delta R is actually
strictly tangent to the curve that's
quite actually Delta R is not strictly
tangent to anything so maybe I should
have another picture if I'm going from
here to here then Delta R is going to be
this arc inside the curve while the
tangent vector will be going in this
direction okay so they are not strictly
parallel to each other and that's why
it's only approximately equal similarly
this distance the length of Delta R is
not exactly the length along the curve
it's actually a bit shorter but if you
imagine a smaller and smaller portion of
a curve then you know this this effect
of the curve being a curve and that the
straight line becomes more negligible if
you zoom into the curve sufficiently
then it looks more and more like a
straight line and then what I said
becomes true in the limit okay any other
questions
No okay
so what happens next
okay so let me show you a nice example
of why we might want to use vectors to
study parametric curves because after
all a lot of words here you can just do
in coordinates and we don't really need
vectors
well actually vectors being a language
you know you never strictly need it but
it's useful to have a notion of vectors
so I want to tell you a bit about
Kepler's second law of celestial
mechanics so that goes back from that
goes back to 1609 so that's not exactly
a recent news okay but still I think
it's a very interesting example of why
you might want to use vector methods to
analyze motions so what happens what
happened back then is Kepler was trying
to observe the motion of planets in the
sky in the sky and trying to come up
with general explanations of how they
move before him people were saying well
we kind of move in a circle but maybe
it's more complicated than that we need
to add smaller circular motions on top
of each other and so on they had more
and more complicated theories and then
Kepler came with these laws that said
basically that planets move in an
ellipse around the Sun and that they
move in a very specific way along that
ellipse
so there's actually three laws but let
me just tell you about the second one
that has a very nice vector
interpretation so what Kepler's second
law says is that the motion of planets
is first of all they move in a plane and
second the higher
swept out by the line from the Sun to
the planet is swept at constant I'm
sorry is swept at constant height from
the Sun to the planet is swept out by
the line at a constant rate okay so
that's an interesting law because it
tells you once you know what we are 'but
if a planet looks like it tells you how
fast it's going to move on that orbit
okay so let me explain again so this law
says you know maybe the Sun let's put
the Sun here at the origin and let's
have a planet
well the planet orbits around the Sun in
some trajectory so this is supposed to
be light blue can you see it as
different from white no okay maneuver
okay doesn't really matter so the planet
moves on its orbit and if you wait for a
certain time then in a bit later it will
be here then here and so on then you can
look at the amount of area you know
inside this triangular wedge and the
claim is that the amount of area in here
is proportional to the time elapsed so
in particular if the planet is closer to
the Sun then it has to go faster and if
it's further away from the Sun when it
has to go slower so that the area
remains forgotten all the time so it's a
very sophisticated prediction and I
think the way he came to it was really
just by using a lot of observations and
trying to measure what things were you
know what was true it wasn't true but
let's try to see how we can understand
that in terms of what we know today
about mechanics so in fact what happens
is that Newton so Newton was quite a bit
later and that was the late 17th century
instead of beginning of the 17th century
so he was able to explain this using his
laws for gravitational attraction and
you'll see that if we will formulate
Kepler's law in terms of vectors then
and if we work a bit with these vectors
we're going to end up with something
that actually and completely obvious to
us now at the time it was very far from
obvious but to us now it's completely
obvious so let's try to see what does
Kepler's law say in terms of vectors
okay
so let's think of what kinds of vectors
we might want to have in here well it
might be good to think of maybe the
position vector and maybe it's variation
so if we wait as an amount of time we'll
have a vector Delta R which is the
change in position vector over a certain
interval of time
okay so let's start with the first step
what's the most complicated thing in
here it's this area swept out by the
line how do we express that area in
terms of vectors
well I've almost given the answer by
drawing this picture right if I take a
sufficiently small amount of time this
base glider engine looks like a triangle
so we have to find the area of a
triangle well we know how to do that now
so the area is approximately equal to
one-half of the area of a parallelogram
that I could form from these vectors and
the area of a parallelogram is given by
the magnitude of a cross-product okay so
I should say this is the area swept in
time delta T and you should think of
delta T as relatively small I mean at
the scale of a planet that might still
be you know a few days but small
compared to the overall trajectory so
now let's remember that the amount a
which removed Delta R is approximately
equal to V times delta T okay I'm just
using what the definition of a velocity
vector so let's use that well sorry so
it's again approximately equal to R
cross V magnitude times delta T I can
take out the delta T which is a scalar
so now what does it mean to say that
area is swept at a constant rate means
this thing is proportional to delta T so
that means
so the last days in fact that the length
of this cross product R cross V equals
constant aquas V has constant length any
questions about that no yes
yes let me try to explain that so what
I'm claiming is that the length of the
cross product R cross V measures the
rate at which area is swept by the
position vector I would say with a
factor of two one half of this length is
the rate at which area is swept how do
we see that well let's take a small time
interval delta T in time delta T our
planet moves by V delta T okay so if it
moves by V delta T it means that this
triangle up there has two sides one is
the position vector R the other one is V
delta T so it's area is given by 1/2 of
the Banga to the cross product that's
the formula we've seen for the area of a
triangle in space so the area is 1/2 of
the cross product R and V delta T
magnitude of the cross product so to say
that the rate at which a I swept is
constant means that these two are
proportional
we are divided by delta T is constant
over time and so this is constant
okay
now what about the other half of the law
well it says that the motion is in a
plane and so you know we have a plane in
which the motion takes place and
contains also the Sun and it contains
the trajectory so let's think about that
plane
well I claim that the position vector is
in the plane that's what we are saying
but there's another vector that I know
is in the plane but you could say give a
position vector at another time at any
time but in fact what's also true is
that the velocity vector is in the plane
if I'm moving in a plane then position
and velocity are in there so the plane
of motion contains R and V so what's the
direction of the cross product R cross V
well it's the direction that's
perpendicular to this plane so it's
normal to the plane of motion and that
means now that actually we've put the
two statements in there into a single
form because we are saying R cross V has
constant length and constant direction
in fact in general you know maybe I
should say something about this so if
you just look at the position vector and
the velocity vector for any motion at
any given time then together of a
determine some plane and that's the
plane that contains the origin the point
and the velocity vector if you want it's
the plane in which the motion seems to
be going at the given time now of course
if your motion is not in a plane then
the plane will change it's somehow the
instant you know the plane in which the
motion is taking place at the given time
and to say that the motion actually
stays in that plane forever means that
this guy will not change direction okay
so
okay so so Kepler's second law is
actually equivalent to saying that R
cross V equals constant equals a
constant vector okay
that's what the law says so in terms of
derivatives
it means D by DT of R cross V is the
zero vector okay now so there's an
interesting thing to know which is that
we can use the usual product rule for
derivatives with vector expressions with
dot products or cross product there's
only one catch which is that when we
differentiate a cross product we have to
be careful that the guy on the Left
stays on the left again the right state
and right okay so if you know UV prime
equals u prime V Plus UV Prime then
you're safe if you know it as u prime V
Plus V prime u then you're not safe okay
so it's been living to watch for so
product rule is okay for taking the
derivative of a dot product where you
don't actually even need to be very
careful about other things a derivative
of a cross product where you just need
to be a little bit more careful okay so
now that we know that we can write this
as dr/dt
cos V + r cross DV DT
okay well let's we formulate things
slightly so dr/dt already has a name in
fact that's V okay that's what we call
the velocity vector so this is V equals
V plus R close what is DV DT that's the
acceleration a equals zero okay so now
what's the next step well we know what V
cross V is because remember a vector
plus itself is always zero okay so so
this is the same as R cross 8 equals 0
and that's the same as saying that you
know the cross product of two vectors is
zero exactly when the parallelogram at
the firm has no area and the way in
which what happens is if they are
actually parallel to each other so that
means the acceleration is parallel to
the position okay so in fact what
Kepler's second law says is that the
acceleration is parallel to the position
vector and since we know that
acceleration is caused by a force that's
equivalent to the fact that the
gravitational force is parallel to the
position vector that means well you know
if you have the Sun here at the origin
and if you have your planet
well the gravitational force caused by
the Sun should go along this line in
fact the law doesn't even say whether
it's going towards the Sun or away from
the Sun well what we know now is that
contraction is two words person but
Kepler's law would also be true actually
if things were going away so in
particular say electric force also has
this property of being towards the
center
so actually if you look at motion of
charged particles in an electric field
caused by your point charge particle it
also satisfies Kepler's law satisfies
the same law okay that's the end for
today thanks